انسى دونالد جي ترامب قابل دونالد
إلفيس ترامب ، نحن نحب إلفيس ، لكن الناس
تركوا يشعرون ، عندما اتخذ الرئيس
خطوة إلى الأمام ، لا ينبغي أن أقول هذا
ستقول إنني مغرور جدًا لأنني
لست سوى  شعر أشقر عندما
كنت أكبر ، قالوا إنني أبدو مثل
إلفيس ، كما ترى أن العديد من العقول المشبوهة
لا ترى أي تشابه صفري.
سبعينيات القرن الماضي ، إلفيس
قليلاً هذا فقط من غريسلاند
إلفيس يتفاعل مع ترامب معتقدًا أنه
يشبهه ولكن هيا ، ألا ترى القليل
من إلفيس وهذه التغريدة علقت عليك أن
تكون القاضي ، فلا شك في أن دونالد
ترامب يحب أن تقارن
بالخير-  يبدو نجوماً ، إنه شاب ، لديه
مظهر روبرت ريدفورد الجميل ،
أنسى الأمر ، لقد أحببت تلك المقدمة ، لكن
إلفيس كان في فئة أخرى بالكامل كنت
أعرف أنه كان شيئًا خاصًا ،
حتى أنه منحه ميدالية
الحرية بعد وفاته.  شعر دونالد إلفيس
ترامب بسجلات في المقابل ، فهو يبدو
وكأنه مقلد إلفيس وهذا
غريب لأن كل مقلدي الفيس
يحبون دونالد ترامب فهم
يحبونني ، كما يعتقد البعض أن
الرئيس وملك موسيقى الروك أند رول يشتركان في أغنية
مشتركة بمجرد الاستماع إلى إلفيس في
شعرت مراسم الميدالية وكأن الرئيس يتمنى أن يتمكن من
الوصول إلى ميكروفون بدلاً من وقته.